fans of true news will already know this
sponsor it is surf shock
wow surf shark they've always looked
after the show and now they want you
to look after them us and yourself but
what are they giving them
well it's kind of surf shark does quite
a few complex things that are very
difficult to explain for someone with a
small mind like you
or i but i can break them down you want
to go anywhere in the world you want to
be able to get into another country's
internet
why maybe you want to log on to netflix
maybe you want to see some
other sports around the world because
it's geo-blocked somewhere in england
so if shark will get you there surf shot
goes oh don't worry about that i can get
you into america we can get you into any
of these places
it's basically like a travel agent but
for the internet right now that's more
important than ever because
travelling is hard very hard it looks
like an experience different culture
absolutely yeah so say you're learning a
new language and you want to put
yourself in italy take yourself to the
netflix in that country
put the subtitles on watch it in spanish
or italian
before you know it you're fully italian
basically mamma mia am i right you might
actually just
want to watch programs in america though
because you've clocked for sure
english netflix you're sure i'm at that
point now right yeah that's what i did
it's an app and browser extension and
not only that it goes across
all of your devices so you're not only
limited to one device you can log in on
your phone you can log in on your laptop
you can log in on your ipad or whatever
other tablet you've got
you're covered for 83 off that's 83
off and three months absolutely free all
you got to do
is head over to the link in the
description and enter code geordie
at checkout you get that straight away
enjoy it enjoy it enjoy it enjoy it
enjoy it
you know that fight that was kind of
happening not happening and now looks
like it is happening
uh floyd mayweather versus logan paul
the press conference
a battle of the charismas you know
designed to hype a fight up between the
two people who are
actually fighting right right it didn't
go according to plan well i kind of did
i kind of want to see the fight a little
more now
a little they frame them both perfectly
originally i thought these two plants
were fighting
the floyd doesn't dress like a man who's
uh 40. like me when i was about eight
years old on holiday
ironically i was the same size as him
when i was it logan dressed for
a weekend away fishing uh and of course
floyd dressed for the tennis
one of the first noticeable things is
floyd mayweather has
hair and a beard now he has had a hair
transplant what um
on his head-on face the beard on the
face looks alright
but i mean it should do he's probably
paid a fortune for it i thought the size
difference would be
more i thought logan was bigger than
what he is i do get the feeling does
that make sense i do get the feeling
though that on the night
when he's not in those those cuban heels
you can still find him
yeah that's very floyd mayweather
floyd's wearing the probably the biggest
trainers he could find yeah
four pairs of socks yeah exactly yeah
what's floyd's normal tactic do you get
in people's heads
it's a weird one because as great as the
years at fighting
he comes across extremely low iq right
higher fighting iq low iq in
everything else right whereas logan's
the almost the complete flip of that
say what you want to say ain't even
targeted
why is it that every boxing event ever
has sound problems
like just get one good sound guy there
are plenty of other shows where i see
all the sound is perfectly good
every boxing show it's like this
am i on oh sorry sorry the trees the
dodgy camera the bad audio
it's just it's
like i want this to be great for i want
logan to make a shitload of money i want
him to be happy
but like as a product trilla have have
done a really
decent job with jake and you you've seen
what
just someone with organization and
understanding the production can do
this ain't that i'm based in this fight
that's fact i don't need floyd clinton
i came out of retirement just to get
re-retired
floyd's furious by the way so logan just
takes the opportunity and goes i'll talk
then
and no it's on this side just going i'm
[__] i need a microphone that works
yeah because his mic does not work but
that would annoy i've i'm surprised he
hasn't reacted worse to that because
that is a bit
it's a bit of an inferiority thing isn't
it's a very insecure man which is why
he well that's why he dress dresses like
that and feels the need to have
hair plugs and spend as much money as he
does and tell everyone constantly how
great he is
to be fair the insecurity is what's
driven him to be great in the ring
in a way it's a strength but he's
massively insecure do you think it's
because he never hears compliments about
the other aspects of his life
so for instance i'm good on camera you
know i'm i'm good in bed i'm a good cook
all these different kinds you've got a
lot of good things i hear multiple good
things on a daily basis about me that
was fantastic food
let's retire the thing with floyd is
everyone goes you are great
in the ring he does own strip clubs so
that's that's pretty much all
that's all else he does again not
something about him though that you can
complain
this is the mad thing about floyd is
when he goes on about as many businesses
and everyone bangs on about what a
genius businessman he is
yeah is he a genius or is he just very
good at boxing and is very dislikable so
people keep paying for the fights hoping
he loses
i sense someone's jealous someone wants
to be good at boxing and dislikable
but also be able to go to his titty bars
at any time he wishes well you've got me
on all three
yeah pipsqueak is the guy
this is the guy that's also a really
good line this is the guy that is a very
good line because first of all he's
unrecognizable from his new hair
but secondly he does look like a pool
boy june 6
tune in come out i'm gonna entertain
we're gonna have fun i don't have to
talk about what i'm gonna do
i don't have to talk about what i'm
going to do it would be very handy if
you could talk about what you are going
to do because that is why we are here
for this
it is it is to promote a fight yeah i
don't need to tell you what i'm going to
do can you give us sort of a ballpark
you see that guy in the bottom corner
there that's leonard ellerbe that guy is
living his best life
this guy is basically living the gta
life you know what i mean this guy's
like i'm one of the downloadable
characters
yeah he gets paid just to sort of be
there sort of thing love that
like me i fight real fighters so guess
what
i'm willing to fight both in the same
night
question is which way around you do that
you definitely do logan first right
it's bollocks floyd also said before he
thought conor mcgregor we'll fight
boxing first and then we'll do mma
second
i see yeah funny old thing that never
happened yeah you know why i've set up
the octagon over there
what was the sorry oh busy busy i'm
going to fight both of the same night
puss and see
yeah you tend to say that as one word
but fair play you're a grandpa
very wise your kids have kids my kids
have kids love my kids love my grandkids
and guess what i'm going to treat you
just like you're one of my grandkids
i'm going to beat the [__] out of you
what nothing if you really wanted to
threaten someone using what you did to a
family member should have chosen his
wife yeah exactly
i'm a wife you logan what nothing
terrified
uh someone check on those kids oh you
walked in with your whole squad of
people
y'all circle jerk each other you got
eight bodyguards no i don't i love i
love
my people i stand behind my people and i
still tell all eight
people in the middle so no one can reach
you ever that's [__] by the way
whenever floyd is out on the street he's
he's surrounded by
giants and he's in the middle he isn't
the guy like he says he is in a ring
with rules and where he can only be
boxed yeah he
and i'm not saying he's not a tough guy
because obviously he is if this was a
an mma fight for example a regular
street fight
logan would annihilate right okay it
would it would be
over in minutes logan was a good
wrestler like he would just take him
down
and beat the living [__] out of him
you'd hope so absolutely yeah
i would i'm on your side now what
oh man it's going to be easy you got
dirty ass air force once
yes jake paul just literally pulled the
shoelaces
from floyd and untied his laces your
shoes untied i just like what an
antagonizer jake is like
in in a situation like this like floyd
mayweather is one of the most
childish you know antagonized as there
is so if you can
level up and outdo him on that which he
has
it's gonna do his [__] heading right
because also if you're better
yeah and jake paul is better at that
yeah for sure
so this is where it started this is
where jake starts
getting under the skin of floyd the
second you cross especially in a fight
thing the second you cross the physical
boundary and start doing even little
things yeah
you're planting seeds in that guy's head
yeah i can do it i can [__] with you
yeah
and for floyd the ego of him he ain't
gonna last
you gotta realize this without
without youtube without the computer
i'm rich i'm wealthy y'all need youtube
i don't
without the television you get no
pay-per-views i don't i don't quite get
what his point is here
technology was created you've exploited
that well without that
you're nothing yeah without the boxing
ring you're nothing just to be clear
without technology we're we're basically
the flintstones at this point yeah
without people being able to watch you
logan you've got no money
all right it's different for you floyd
because you get paid regardless if
people watch you or not don't you
just remind me of your business model
realistically if we're going to talk
about who's smart out of logan and floyd
when floyd was logan's age
he was not worth one tenth of what logan
is worth not even close i know what he
did to the country of japan i knew what
he did to japan so guess what
you have to pay for what you did to
japan oh so so floyd brings up you know
as we all knew he brings up the
suicide forest i know what you did to
japan so guess what you've got to pay
for what you did to japan
floyd ever the advocate for the japanese
can can we just see what what floyd did
to a japanese man just out of
this kid kickboxer mma fighter was set
up in a boxing match with floyd he
normally fights at about 125 pounds
floyd normally fights at about 145
somewhere around there
floyd's four inches taller than him like
he has all the experience everything he
just beat the brakes off of this young
kid
he ends up making him cry
this fight hasn't even gone a full round
and nasa's corner has thrown in the
towel and said so yeah
um we see what you've done to japan as
well i suppose then floyd
got about 10 million for that apparently
well at least the other guy got
something good then just to turn up and
basically beat the [__] out of another
guy that wasn't even in his way
much smaller no actual boxing matches to
my knowledge
right i just beat the hell out of him
yeah great a great man flight yeah a
great man i respect the [__] out of you
floyd
well i know what you did to your wife
one thing
can we just do uh research for those who
don't know
how many wives does floyd mayweather
have while the boxer is never married he
is a father to four children two
daughters and two sons floyd is a loving
and responsible father who wrote this
floyd when it comes to romance the
boxer's love life has been
marred should we say by an appalling
record of domestic violence
good mayweather's violent abuse of women
has reportedly got him in trouble with
the law and seen him
jailed so reportedly he's got him in
trouble with the law i think when you
get in trouble the law you tend to get
jailed
you know if it's if you've reportedly
been in trouble with the law and you've
been jailed you don't have to say
reportedly anymore
exactly
he served two months of a three-month
sentence in prison in 2012
after attacking his ex josie harris two
years earlier the horrific assault
is described in harris book took place
in front of their three kids
who were aged 7 9 and 11. if they paid
the pay-per-view you've got to give them
what they paid for
grabbed her by the hair while she was
still sleeping
drugged her around the room of her home
in vegas like a rug
before punching her repeatedly in the
head screaming i'll [__] kill you
that does not look like the man who
knows what he's been jailed for
yeah i mean he looks fairly happy he
thought he was being taken on a
ride-along with the cops you know where
you get to see
what a cop does for a day he didn't
fully understand this is the thing he's
not that bright he's not that smart they
weren't floyd can you take your photo
absolutely another woman there in 2001
uh mayweather punch melissa brim the
mother of his daughter
iana in an argument in las vegas
shopping center
i know when i'm in public i think of
beating my spouse
a year later he punched two of harris's
female friends in a nightclub sorry i
thought he was going to punch a cheetah
i'm really worried there was going to be
animal abuse then and chased him out of
the venue he again
received a suspended sentence for the
two counts of battery
in order to undergo impulse control
counseling right
he should go on the impulsive podcast
chantelle jackson was then later engaged
to floyd mayweather in 2013 but
ultimately when they broke up
she sued him for invasion of privacy
assault battery harassment
and the infliction of emotional distress
along with other
charges so i'm not sure having a
relationship with floyd mayweather
is a good idea at this point i'm really
not let's just leave that there because
you know if you do see him on a dating
app yeah
probably just wait for bill gates yeah
yeah he's the
rich guy you want he's frail you beat
him up easy oh yeah
he's about as solid as windows vista got
him
guardium because xp was actually a very
solid operating yeah it was underrated
yeah it was only floyd's 15-0 nah he's
51-1 he beat his wife too
that is such a like oh it doesn't even
look at him doesn't it
yeah let's see what floyd says he's
entitled to fear how do you want to feel
say what do you want to say
let's go there yeah we know you're in a
press conference bro i'm pretty sure
you're entitled to say what the [__]
you are entitled to feel how you feel
you just caught
he just called you out for being a wife
beer you said nothing yeah you're
entitled to feel like you want to feel
really not stating feel into your
floyd i don't think that's a feeling do
you want to dispute that there floyd
you're entitled to feel and say what you
want he didn't even deny it it's just
my thing is this you have to always have
proof
absolutely which the courts did have and
ultimately you were convicted of things
and served some prison time
ultimately we will just for two months
by the way let's not forget yeah this is
floyd money mayweather the man would
have had the
best lawyers and money could buy and he
still went to prison
always have proof so one thing they know
about me
they say are you reading from a
teleprompter but one thing that i do
oh no you
some people haven't haven't had the
privilege of education and i get the
feeling that maybe he didn't have that
privilege so i wouldn't pick on the
reading
i'd leave that to one side pick on the
wife pick on the wife beating because
the wife beating he did
the reading he can't one day we know us
as black people
we die for what we believe in we stand
for what we believe in
and a lot of us got killed and died for
reason so i don't worry about that
why are you making this about race
because it's always about race
what the [__] does he talk this is the
worst this is
you can't read i do i did wonder what a
25 year old logan paul
and a 44 year old floyd mayweather would
be like it's just god awkward isn't it
like so
floyd he's starting to sound and talk
more like an out of touch old man
and logan's just sort of laughing at him
you beat your wife you can feel how you
want to feel
you can't read we die for what we
believe in
sorry what it's just awkward do you know
what i mean who's the last guy you
knocked out
um this has been a bad press conference
there's no two ways about it it's been
awful the chat is terrible yeah
i'm gonna look at that with fonz this is
desperately needed a mediator
to get in the middle ask them questions
and give them stuff to go off because
floyd's not smart still trying to hook
your wares huh no but
no like eddie hearn any [__] promoter
they they need someone in the middle
to give them something to work with
because right now floyd going off his
own head
it's painful yeah and logan let him sort
of just gas himself yeah logan lets him
dig his grave and then just keep
shoveling it with him and say he needs a
little more debt in there yeah
logan says the funny things as floyd
makes himself look stupid
it's just oh adult when ben askren and
jake paul were going at each other
ben's a witty guy yeah you know what i
mean and jake's good at the insults and
good at getting under someone's good
yeah it was entertaining
yeah this is awkward what's up you want
to run it two and one night
you want to run it one more time
absolutely let's do it let's make it
happen let's make it happen
by the way this guy what's this guy's
name again leonard ellerbe leonard ella
be
always wearing the same [__] smile oh
it's jay paul look at that
he's just happy to be like you can see
him just sitting there going i'm getting
my percentage yeah
i'm [__] hey jake how are you another
one he is the
the dj khaled of fighting he he's there
he's sort of around setting it up but he
doesn't have to be the one actually
doing
the performance performing so he just
takes all the credit absolutely
let's do it let's make it happen let's
make it happen yes sir
two guys just agreeing in the same room
let's make it happen okay well we'll
make it happen
absolutely let me call y'all come on
what happens
just to be clear that was jake paul
stealing
floyd mayweather's hat not his rolex
not his you know million pound chain
that was a
you know two dollar hat well well i
don't know and floyd sells on the web we
should probably check the price of that
the mark of
25 yeah the point is all of these men
chasing after jake paul
for a [__] hat well i'm gonna just
pause something here and you'll probably
see why
does not look good someone went to
turkey didn't they it's the hair
replacement
he doesn't this is why he's a bit
triggered is because your hair looks
[__] well i don't know the beard i
actually think does look good
considering it's a thick absolutely i
think it's very matte
yeah i mean where did they take those
hairs from is the worry do you know what
i mean
it's just a [__] hatman you can't let
someone violate you like that though can
you
violate yeah he took a hat yeah i know
but someone runs away with my hat i'm
gonna be like it's the precious hat
though
like precious hat of a grandma am i am i
it's a [__] hat everyone's going on
like he's
he's stolen a [__] jewel like this is
not the diamond on the titanic
this is not worth [__] i think it's
because you're a [__] you wouldn't
fight jake paul
they're all getting their shots in on
jake paul this is you guys are punching
this guy in the head for a hat
logan
oh now they've broken up and jake's off
into this direction
suddenly and floyd miller saying don't
ever disrespect me right it's a [__]
heart man
[__] him up we're not in prison bro not
anymore anyway right floyd
all right i know we're in the fight
business here and this is what this is
all about but you're not in a ring you
can't you
this you just can't just carry on like
that no you know what i mean
it's a joke boxing's meant to have some
sort of integrity there is no
integrity with floyd there is absolutely
zero zilch
like some boxers then this is my problem
is like that's why
you always look to certain other
fighters who have a lot more credibility
about them sure
this is the type of [__] you get with
floyd he's a [__]
you can see he's still laughing jake is
still laughing he's causing ut
mayhem people are trying to beat the
hell out of him he's got his hands he's
clearly trying to protect himself but
he's still laughing he's enjoying it
because he knows
he is the joker he is the one who just
wants to watch the world burn
right while he's laughing this is the
problem with this we had a press
conference
for logan versus floyd and jake's the
one who went yeah let me stir this [__]
up yeah it's perfect it's
it worked he stole the show like
literally like floyd is still triggered
even now
even though they're trying to rough jake
up jake is still laughing
um you know how the judge sent them to
those self-management classes
i'm not sure they worked no just a hunch
jake's made them all look stupid in my
opinion
yeah he's actually made he showed how
silly this is
it's what happens when you work for an
insecure little man that absolutely yeah
like he's made
all of the bodyguards and and floyd
himself just looked like you're a 44
year old man
dressed like a [__] 10 year old
running after your cap when you've had a
dodgy hair replacement that's been
exposed that's the point it's
embarrassing
to watch do you know what i mean like
it's not great jake did a tech talk
about it about to steal floyd
mayweather's hat i'll let you guys know
how it goes let's make it happen
get the bed working with this boat
absolutely
let me call y'all my homeboy on my own
one night
[Music]
this is the weird thing is floyd was
always the antagonizer floyd's always
been the bell end i
i don't know how this all works now like
obviously in
a boxing ring everyone's going to be
picking floyd no matter who he's against
in this scenario because of the way
jake's playing him
i wonder if people will start liking
jake because he's i think people are
toying with him clearly and also he
isn't [__] around with youtubers
anymore
no he's playing with professional
fighters who have
massive egos and think they're the
toughest guys even if they could beat
him it that doesn't even matter at this
point it's about him
playing with fire and and it's funny
it's hilarious yeah it's great to watch
the weird situation now we've got is
jake paul has been on a massive role in
boxing
he's put his name in the mainstream
everyone knows who he is he's shown he
can do it in the ring you've got drake
dm and him all of this sort of [__] he's
then went and pissed floyd off way worse
than logan did
people are going to want to say jake
versus floyd
more now than logan versus flight and
before this fight
it didn't feel like the anticipation for
logan versus floyd was that great anyway
because no one's giving logan a chance
publicly and
what what jake was very good at doing is
getting a lot of people to be divided on
him versus ben
some people gave him a chance some
people completely didn't give him a
chance when there's a debate
you're doing something right with floyd
and logan there is no debate people
don't feel the need to tune in
because they feel like they know what's
going to happen already whereas at least
with
jake because of this bit of hatred now
from floyd it seems like he really hates
jake he's made people care
and as good as that is for entertainment
it ain't good if the fight you're
selling
is logan versus floyd it does play into
the bigger narrative
and i think that's why people are still
going to watch it because on the night
it's going to be very similar to when
is it ksi sort of thing all over it
that's what i mean yeah like they've
just switched
ksio for floyd mayweather
so before it was after ksi
for logan and won he would then fight
jake
this is basically what they're gonna do
if if floyd beats logan which everyone
seems to expect that he will it's then
set up him to fight jake
and jake will be ringside jake will step
in jake will there'll be a little face
off you know either that or you'll be in
the ring going
there was someone you wanted to call out
this was before the deji fight
jake paul sort of was going to be
trained by floyd you know i'm his
manager miss train
that's right you know when it comes to
the fight game support him following
money mayweather and yes he's a part of
the money team yo it's over bro
and you know it and you know it oh wow
they used to be friends this is even
better
conor mcgregor's had something to say
about it hey leonard ellerbe you know
the
oh there what the [__] is floyder the
kid curled up
didn't the kid being jake paul the kid
curled up didn't fight back once and
floyd is still running around acting the
tough guy the kid actually pulled the
shambles of a situation meaning jake
saved it
yeah because it was it was bad yeah
floyd is in
out of the drain for him he should thank
him it's
embarrassing he will not scratch 10
million for this fight
and he knows it it was cancelled once
already the world is watching this on
twitter he'd fight a half decent pro and
command 20 million upwards
yeah it's this [__] whatever way you
spin this it's sad
fight someone for real on your record or
[__] off me
slap head floyd always you know had a
lot of respect from the boxing community
and that same boxing community has
trashed
youtube boxing right so for floyd to get
into
business bed with the paul brothers it
damages his credibility because it shows
floyd for what he really is
like it ain't about the sport of boxing
the art of boxing for him it is
all about money money over everything
credibility
he should have more than enough money in
his bank account that he does not need
to
make himself look like a pratt and and
if you think he looks like anything
other than a pratt
from what we've seen today a 44 year old
man dressed like a 10 year old
chasing after his cat that a youtuber
stole from him
i don't know what i can't help you no
like exactly i mean i can't help him
i'll give him one piece of advice and
but this isn't financial advice floyd
put it all in we'll bleep that out to
the put it all in crypto put it up yeah
well it's not financial advice let's
talk about manscaped but every time we
talk about manscape we talk about this
sure it gets their hairs up your nose
and it is fantastic but it's not the
only thing they do also
you can unscrew it and then get rid of
the hairs yeah like this and then pop it
back
on and just pop it back on there and
then pop it back up your nose or someone
else's nose yeah exactly
you have to ask permission so you're
gonna do it with anyone else consent is
important absolutely don't just sort of
sit on the tube and go
you know shock but they also do other
things like say
they've also got the lawnmower 3.0 which
you know trims the balls and the glitch
and all of that yeah yeah
a fantastic bit of kit and then they
also give you these lovely little
sprayers
they've written their philosophy on the
side of this well of course they have
laurence our grooming
must-haves are designed to help you
unleash your individuality
that is true though because if you if
you go with a girl right
first time and she notices that your
bollocks smell amazing that's gonna set
you apart from the pack wow
all the other men's bowls smell like
sweaty balls
your balls smells smell like that
amazing that smells like a bit cologney
it's got like a mask to it
it actually does actually that smells
better than most aftershave and guess
what
it's for sensitive skin as well smell my
balls it's not going to be
like irritating you no so overall pretty
good
these core products these complementary
products and there are loads of other
things on the manscape website get them
all
dot com forward slash true use the code
true 20
off free shipping that's 20 off and free
shipping you're welcome do i need to say
it again you're welcome no exactly
enjoy it enjoy it enjoy it enjoy it
enjoy this is the next slot of youtube
boxers um
or tw tick tock but whatever tick tock
boxing
big box tick box you've got a tick tock
versus youtube event coming soon
obviously we'll be supporting big gibber
who's fighting on the card
are you talk or tube huh this is one of
the main chord uh fighters uh bryce hall
he's fighting
austin austin mcbroom austin mcbroom is
that his real life
will he sweep up before this video
begins don't forget that i will be
flying out five random pau club
subscribers out to la
to come party with the party animal
that's completely sober i'm a
charisma-less [__] but it turns out that
if you just do some things on tick-tock
you might get famous
so i saw the guy in person and his
energy completely changed in person yes
i would [__] you up
you'll [__] me now it's the kind of
banter you just love to see on camera
i'm going to [__] you up you want to
[__] me now
this boxing club has the nicest
wallpaper by the way
i'm not convinced this is a real boxing
club two camp guys
watch boxing videos this boxing club has
oh my god
i pushed you you sat there like a little
[__] the veins on this kid's neck i
know
wow looks like that yeah it's true right
now it's true
so yeah interestingly um they don't show
all of the the fight
um which i get you want to trim some of
the fat out but there's been a there's
been a lot of trimming
it's also we're gonna well it's not this
is youtube no this is tick-tock
a lot of wrestling this needs a
technical analysis
they let go i mean you know clearly the
both guys are just still learning
um which is fine but just don't act like
you're the baddest man on the planet
right yeah
when you clearly don't know what the
[__] you're doing yourself he's reaching
uh over and he's sort of punching while
running yeah i think he threw a double
punch at one point i'm not sure that's
taught in any boxing classes they should
teach that that's a really good idea i
mean realistically no can't defend
in the words of mr miyagi exactly yeah
they've done if done properly
but only you've done proper only have
done properly and that's why very few
people attempt it
when one of them is open
why does nice tyson ever do that exactly
beat the this
this yeah exactly what the double punch
take that he used to shout out the true
geordie double punch
yeah it's well it's not it's legendary
it's the blonde friend of bryce hall's
double puncher
i understand what this guy has done he's
worked out how to look like a boxer he
does that thing where he goes
as long as you raise your shoulders a
bit looks like you're loosening
something up like ready to let it go
it looks like you're gonna cry you're
ready yeah let's see if he can crack
definitely not right definitely not i'm
not expecting him to be perfect i'm
certainly not perfect myself but he's
acting like he's great and that's where
the issue is
the kid actually who he's um fighting
this kid in the blue heart he ducks
quite well but
i don't know what his hands are doing
like at this point if he throws at the
same time
he's going to smash his wide open he's
then dropped his right hand
dramatically bryce hole so he's left his
chin
wide open here he swings and a miss
again
he's bad and that's because he's new
don't get me wrong but
again he's not acting that way no you
know what i'm saying i feel like he's
got that early false confidence thing
that you get when you first start boxing
you're like hey i'm good
you have that if you don't get in there
with anyone who knows what they're doing
right because the minute you do you get
schooled
[__] yeah that's not great you see he's
got all his girls around the back yeah
all of his little fans very much like
when you train
just exactly like that yeah that is a
solid shot he wobbled him a little there
like his neck went
really that's all you got
really that's all you got what the the
one good punch of this entire round
well i mean yeah that's that's all
you've got oh no i'm just warming up oh
okay good well
show me more later genuinely a lot of
the time when a fighter smiles
after getting hit or acknowledges it in
any way it's because you can't ignore it
you can't
you have to accept you got me there yeah
the point is the kid he's fighting is
garbage and he's inexperienced
yeah yeah and he still managed to land a
good punch on him if he if this kid in
the in
the blue head guard knew anything bryce
hall would be in trouble yeah bryce hall
is showing a massive lack of experience
and that's fine unless you've got a
fight coming up in a matter of
weeks months yeah then it's it's a it's
a worry
they've got a lot of work to do if he
wants to get in there and look
anything like a boxer because right now
he looks nothing like a boxer i'll give
him props he stepped in the ring
what the next round he would have
literally been asleep probably out of
boredom rather than an actual box
yeah you would have been you would have
been slept so bad in the next round why
were you gonna sing me a lullaby
i mean yeah he he may have beaten him up
and got the kid
give up there was no sign of any real
power from him
at all and it's not because he doesn't
have any power probably he just doesn't
know how to [__] use his body
properly right austin mcbroom this guy
is a grown ass man though he looks like
a kid to me i'll say with broon is like
he's the head of a family like he's got
his own
ace family yeah where he just basically
[__] this woman
uh there's the punch there's the punch
[Music]
he [__] hurt him there didn't he
i like that oh that was a pretty weak
completely different it's not a case of
athleticism though it's like austin
mcbroom maybe just understands boxing a
bit better but you know it's knowing how
to place it how to turn into the punch
like i i haven't seen anything of austin
mcbroom in a ring but if he knows
anything
bryce hall's losing well we can't find
any of our sim up in boxing but we can
find some of
deji talking all right what's up guys
it's deji
so i have a fight june 12th against
vinnie hacker
is deji on the other card for this yeah
yeah he's fighting on it he's
making his grammar for him yeah let's
dive into this let's see
what vinnie hacker does on uh the old
tic-tock
when did you lost to jake paul jake paul
was a big name
yeah and he was not humiliated you know
there was nothing humiliating in losing
to jake at that time this guy's
snuggling up with a [__] extra large
teddy bear i get that but deji is
already watching him from heaven look at
that circle true
yeah looking down from from the pearly
gates
[Music]
no face no picture how the [__] is this
a [__] career
at least on youtube we had to [__]
say [__] he's not even lip syncing
properly this is half lip singing
[Music]
deji you have to win it's like you
cannot let this guy beat you the guy's
in good shape
[__] hell man look he might be a nice
guy whoever you might have a good sense
of humor this might all be part of an
act
he might be very self-aware yeah i don't
doubt it oh he's the biggest bell end
ever either or
deji we need you to win we're praying
for you we're gonna need this
uh for just for youtube in general oh
absolutely you know deji's now our ben
askren
right we can't let that beat one of our
lives deji we back you 100
come on if you need any help with
training or anything absolutely we're
happy to like come in and you know throw
punches for you so gibb is fighting
someone called taylor hold the holder a
famous
tick tocker there's a little bit of
footage of him sure do you want to see a
little bit of taylor holder yeah yeah
sure okay right
right so the guy in the red t-shirt is
taylor holder yeah so what i'm saying
here
he knows where to put his hands he backs
up nicely quite well
he leans out the way and then a lovely
uppercut
on the guy who was coming in i mean and
he's moving well
you know double jab catches him coming
in again
head movement combination and he moves
off well so
he's definitely got a good solid basic
understanding of boxing
this is not what we've seen from bryce
yeah this is someone who's got at least
a year or two
minimum really yeah at least i i would
say good luck to the kid well not not
really i mean nothing against him but
he's fighting gibson
all right okay so bad luck to the kid
but this is how gibb's feeling
what's this taylor holder donnie gonna
do
throw it back he's got nothing on me
he's got nothing on me i've been
training
psychotically every day since my last
fight this i mean if i was taylor i'd be
looking at this and going i'm fighting a
[__]
psychopath did can i just absolutely
confirm that yeah out of all of them
taylor looks probably the better boxer
of all of the lads on the cod that i've
seen
i'm going off breadcrumbs i haven't seen
a lot of footage but
gibb is the hardest he's the toughest
one out of the lot there's no doubt in
my mind he is the one who
is going to take a shotgun to stop him
and
in miami we're not talking about actual
shock yeah
the crime over there yeah um that isn't
happening this time gabe's winning this
one gabe is going to overwhelm him
with pressure he is going to show some
people some things they've not seen
before
from gabe gabe's going to smash him and
i'm going to predict it oh i'm going to
give an early prediction
four rounds in clearly five maybe i
think they've got like a five-round
fight
and it's just gonna be like an
overwhelming onslaught from gabe
where he's just going to be piling on
the pressure
piling it on and that kid is gonna get a
body shot and he's just gonna go down
and then and then when you get up it's
going to be you won't want to go back up
you can't have that thing where you go i
don't think he wants this yeah there you
go he's going to take his heart
yeah gib is going to take us hard the
key for this is the less
women around the ring the better right
because if taylor's got something to
look across and go like they don't love
me anymore
so have some real hard-looking cancer
yeah yeah oh just really ugly women
would do
i've ordered my food now great well that
gives us time
to wrap up true news it's been emotional
sometimes it's been [__]
well of course but this is all the
internet has got to offer us
so that's what you're being served we
hope you enjoyed it do
click the links on the sponsors keep
buying stuff keep us in the good books
the good graces of our sponsors
and we will see you on the next one